HERE'S WHAT YOU DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE AT&T
COMMERCIAL GIRL
Everybody loves Lily, AT&T's perky, enthusiastic
commercial spokeswoman.
Based on her TV ads, we know she's nerdy and
awkward, a hopeless romantic, and she likes
bedazzling.
But how much do you actually know about the
lady behind the Lily?
Here's what you may not have known about the
AT&T commercial girl.
MILANA VAYNTRUB
This might blow your mind, but Lily's name
isn't actually Lily.
It's actually Milana Aleksandrovna Vayntrub.
Vayntrub was born in the Uzbek Soviet Socialist
Republic, or what's now the Republic of Uzbekistan.
You know what they say: give us your tired,
your poor, and your huddled masses yearning
to become Hollywood pop-culture sensations.
POLITICAL REFUGEE
Life in the USSR wasn't exactly sunshine and
rainbows for the Vayntrubs, especially because
they faced persistent religious persecution
for being Jewish in an officially atheist
country.
When Milana was two, her family fled Uzbekistan
in hopes of finding religious freedom and
political asylum in America.
The process was long and grueling, with the
family stranded in both Austria and Italy
for a while.
Luckily, the Vayntrubs made it to America
and settled in California, which sounds like
a wonderful step up.
BARBIE AND ER
Lily is hardly the first character Vayntrub
ever played in a commercial.
She began acting in TV ads at five, starring
in Barbie commercials to help her family make
ends meet.
Her first big break happened in 1995, when
she landed a guest spot on ER, where she appeared
alongside stars like Julianna Margulies at
the precocious and precious age of eight!
HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUT
Vayntrub attended Beverly Hills High School,
but she dropped out as a sophomore.
But not because she didn't value her education.
She actually wanted to learn more quickly.
Vayntrub got her GED and moved on to the University
of San Diego, where she earned a degree in
communication—appropriate considering she's
known for selling AT&T products.
UCB GRAD
The Upright Citizen's Brigade is one of the
most famous comedy troupes in show business.
Vayntrub honed her comedy chops with the UCB,
joining other famous graduates like Saturday
Night Live vets Kate McKinnon, Bobby , and
Horatio Sanz, to name only a few.
She may not have made the SNL cast yet, but
her work with the UCB helps explain her comedic
timing.
YOUTUBE SENSATION
Vayntrub has guest starred on shows like Key
and Peele, Californication, and Silicon Valley.
But before all that, she rose to prominence
through a different channel—on YouTube.
As one of the co-creators of Live Prude Girls,
Vayntrub was an early YouTube sensation, with
each of her videos earning hundreds of thousands
of views.
The channel is dormant now, but if you want
a sneak peek at life before Lily, you can
still watch Vayntrub's hit videos online.
Bonus points if you watch from an AT&T device...
THE CAN'T DO NOTHING MOVEMENT
Vayntrub created the "Can't Do Nothing" movement,
which has spurred nearly a quarter of a million
people worldwide to use social media to help
crusade for the rights of refugees around
the globe.
Saving the world by using your AT&T phone
to record YouTube videos of yourself helping
refugees?
That's just the kind of moment Lily would
absolutely love.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to share your favorite
Lily moment!